[Musik]
so natürlich hattet ihr nichts mit der
Explosion im Chemieraum zu tun
so wie Bill Clinton nichts mit Monica
Lewinski zu tun hatte ja neyland
Nintendo wer ist Bill Clinton
ja das ist heute unser nachsitzthema
us-präsidentinnen wobei vergesst das
Gendern vielen Dank auch Hillary Clinton
also im Jahr 1789 wurde George washing
nur die Highlights mehr könnt ihr euch
eh nicht merken ne
Washington erster Präsident ab 1789 das
ist so lange her da war nicht mal Joe
Biden geboren
versteht ihr bei beiden sehr alt ist
egal nach 8 Jahren hat Washington den
Job abgegeben deshalb darf bis heute
kein US-Präsident länger regieren als
acht Jahre oder wie Wladimir Putin sagen
würde Aufwärmphase
tja danach Männer Männer als Präsidenten
nicht alle erleben das Ende ihrer
Amtszeit siehe ihr hier Abraham Lincoln
hat die Sklaverei abgeschafft dann im
Bürgerkrieg die Südstaaten besiegt aber
dann wurde er bei einem Theaterbesuch
erschossen was lernen wir daraus
geht nicht ins Theater da warten nur
Attentäter oder noch grausamer
das Aldinger
[Applaus]
so nach linken gab es wieder
massigtestosteron bis auf einen süßen
Moment als sie oder Rose world sich
angeblich geweigert hat einen Bären zu
erschießen deshalb wurde er zum
Namensgeber für etwas das bis heute in
keinem Kinderzimmer fehlen darf nämlich
was
die Pampa
fast den Teddybären so dann wieder ein
Haufen Männer merkt euch einfach
irgendwann heißt sogar wieder einer
Roosevelt Franklin die Bruce wird durfte
während des Zweiten Weltkriegs
ausnahmsweise 12 Jahre regieren
vielleicht weil sein New Deal die
Wirtschaft aus der Krise gebracht hat
vielleicht aber auch nur weil er ein
besonders putziges Haustier hatte
Terrier ist aber auch viel mehr als ein
Hund fahler hatte säckeweise Fanpost
eine eigene cartoon-reihe Auftritte in
Filmen so ein Megastar gab es im Weißen
Haus nicht mehr bis zu John F Kennedy
wendet in der Kubakrise ein Weltkrieg ab
dann 1963
entscheidet Kennedy plötzlich doch
lieber mit Martin Luther King eine
Surfschule auf Maui aufzumachen
ach Leute das sind wirklich Basics
wirklich nichts Surfschule kennedy wurde
erschossen von Leah wie Oswald mein
Bruder meinte kennedy wurde vom FBI
umgebracht ja weiter
kommen wir zum größten Skandal in der
Geschichte des Weißen Hauses jetzt
endlich Trump okay sagen wir der größte
Skandal der auch als Skandal behandelt
wurde Watergate Richard Nixon hat
einfach das Hauptquartier der
gegnerischen Demokraten komplett
Verwandten lassen er wird der einzige
Präsident der zurücktritt und die USA
geloben ab sofort bespitzeln Sie nur
noch den Rest der Welt und befreundete
Politiker im Weißen Haus Folgen dieses
Olaf Scholz double dieser Erdnuss Farmer
und dieser Schauspieler kein Witz Ronald
Reagan war erst Schauspieler dann
Präsident das wäre als Ventil Schweiger
schlechtes Beispiel danach George Bush
der mit dem Golfkrieg
und
Bill Clinton ganz vielseitig
talentierter Mann Clinton war unter
anderem fürs Saxophon Blasen bekannt ja
apropos Blasmusik besonders berühmt
geworden ist der natürlich für seine
Affäre mit einer Praktikantin nicht
nachmachen
damit werdet ihr heute höchstens noch
Chefredakteur bei der Bild so dann haben
wir es fast geschafft fehlt noch
George Bush Sohn vom anderen George Bush
ist aber trotzdem auch der mit dem
Golfkrieg das verwirrend aber egal jetzt
zeige ich euch mal wie ein richtiger
muster-präsident aussieht
[Applaus]
auch ich als Frau darf Männer nicht
sexualisieren schon gar nicht Männer die
einfach die Bundeskanzlerin abgehört
haben Alter meine Eltern haben 400 €
bezahlt um Obama live zu sehen das ist
ein Politiker ja ein richtig ernst zu
nehmen der Politiker ganz im Gegensatz
zu seinem Nachfolger über den ich mich
weigere hier zu reden
lustigen Teil lassen sie weg lustig
soll ich dir mal zeigen wie sich vier
Jahre Trump angefühlt haben
hast vergessen jetzt bringst du das hier
wieder hoch
aber ich
werde mich an euch ihr sitzt morgen
wieder nach
und dann erkläre ich euch das
amerikanische Wahlsystem
also für alle die das nicht checken das
heißt ihr kommt hier nicht raus bis
Weihnachten das können sie nicht machen
was wollt ihr noch hier nach sitzen ist
vorbei ja ich habe ja wohl auch mal ein
Recht auf Feierabend oder nicht
guckt euch doch noch ein paar Filmchen
an wie wäre es denn damit zum Beispiel
die hier